bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de ski my les
hôpitaux les ehpad l'aide aux seniors
nous allons parler santé le territoire
se dote d'un nouveau contrat local de
santé pour répondre aux enjeux actuels
et de demain alors quid de la santé sur
l'agglomération ont fait le point c'est
parti
[Musique]
et
tant qu'on a la santé
tout va c'est pourquoi depuis près de 20
ans le territoire a pris la thématique à
bras le corps vieillissement de la
population hausse des maladies
chroniques affections de longue durée
inégalités d'accès aux soins sont les
nouveaux enjeux de santé pour s'y
adapter saint quentin en yvelines se
dote d'un nouveau contrat local de santé
pour 2018 2022 fois on va essayer de
développer un partenariat un peu plus
grand les gens avec qui nous allons
travailler à compter de journée 2018
ça va déjà être l'hôpital de versailles
la clinique privée de trappes où on
envie on va travailler aussi avec la
faculté de médecine dont de saint
quentin et bien sûr tous les ccas deux
des douze communes et
et tous les partenaires aussi sociaux
tout ce qui est aussi les médecins pour
ce nouveau contrat local trois axes
premièrement améliorer l'observation de
l'état socio sanitaire de la population
et définir les besoins
l'institut de promotion de la santé
permet d'effectuer une veille de santé
publique minutieuse du territoire on a
comme mission de travailler à la
réduction des inégalités sociales de
santé depuis 2000 12 ans n'a pu mettre
en place au sein de vitesse des ateliers
en direction de la population des
habitants les ateliers sur les questions
de santé environnement sur le corps
humain prévention la prise en charge du
cancer
et puis les derniers nés des ateliers ça
va des ateliers sur l'aromathérapie la
phytothérapie 30 à 50 ateliers sont
organisés
quinze mille personnes y participent
chaque année une population qui peut
également effectuer un bilan de santé
complet auprès de lits ps avant de se
voir orientés vers des médecins
généralistes ou spécialistes du
territoire l'ip et s organise aussi des
rencontres et ateliers pour les aidants
familiaux
au programme groupes de paroles
sophrologie apprentissage de l'auto
massage afin de soulager ces personnes
dans leur quotidien depuis novembre li
ps a aussi la charge du dispositif sport
sur ordonnance un des moyens
des leviers que nous collectivités on
peut avoir pour agir sur les
problématiques de maladies chroniques
c'est de travailler à la fois sur
l'alimentation et à la fois sur le sport
des études démontrent en effet les
bienfaits du sport sur des maladies très
diverses telles que le cancer les
maladies neurodégénératives ou encore le
diabète
il permet le maintien de bonnes
conditions de santé et retard de la
maladie professionnelle du sport et de
santé travail donne deux concerts dans
le cadre de ce dispositif
d'autres ateliers devraient bientôt voir
le jour sur l'agglomération
[Musique]
ça c'est pour le premier axe le deuxième
permet de consolider le parcours de
santé des populations vulnérables
seniors personnes malades en situation
de précarité ou de handicaps comme ici
au maire en tête à manille les ânes ou
les équipes de l'accueil de jour de
l'association pour l'insertion
l'éducation les soins assure une prise
en charge au quotidien des personnes
âgées à travers un service à domicile de
soins infirmiers un service handicap ou
un service d'évaluation pour la maladie
d'alzheimer
les personnes sont d'abord rencontrés en
consultation mémoire une évaluation
globale permet de parler
de la pathologie avec la personne et
avec la famille on est rentrés les
patients viennent une à deux fois par
semaine
médecins infirmières psychologues et
psychomotricienne se relaient les
objectifs tout d'abord c'est lutter
contre l' isolement social maintenir les
capacités existantes des personnes ayant
des troubles cognitifs en adaptant des
activités
qui sont personnalisés ce jour là c'est
pétanque en intérieur mauvais temps
oblige
[Musique]
plus tard l'équipe entame une partie de
loto histoire de travailler la mémoire
14 activités artistiques cognitive ou
encore des tentes
comme les promenades et les sorties
socioculturel à la médiathèque des
rencontres intergénérationnelles sont
aussi organisées
cet accueil est aussi un moment de répit
pour les aidants familiaux qui trouve
écoute et soutien psychologique
de l'autre côté du couloir qui est
service handicap
le service d'accueil jour handicap
accueille des hommes et des femmes en
situation de handicap
bien sûr c'est un handicap assez
hétérogène on a des personnes qui sont
déficientes intellectuelles les
personnes qui ont des troubles
autistiques ou des personnes aussi
qu'ils ont des troubles psychiatriques
mais stabilisé ces personnes ne sont
confiés par donc la maison
départementale des personnes handicapées
mdph et elles viennent ici pour pouvoir
de se ressourcer partager du temps les
uns avec les autres
sourire sur les territoires on vivre un
concile dans la cité et enfin soulager
les familles une éducatrice spécialisée
deux aides médico psychologiques et un
moniteur éducateur entoure les patients
après un petit déjeuner partagé
la journée démarre ce jour là c'est
maquettes et bricolage l'immense parc
permettent également de jardiner et
depuis peu une ferme a vu le jour
le tout pour poursuivre l'épanouissement
les connaissances et compétences des
personnes et les accompagner dans leur
transition de vie certaines vivent
seules ou en couple à domicile d'autres
en foyer de vie ou d'hébergement
d'autres chez leurs parents
vieillissants les aider à passer le cap
de la vie d'après ce sens leurs proches
fait partie du travail de l'accueil de
jour pour cette nouvelle vie des
familles d'accueil sont particulièrement
recherchées l'offre de soins c'est le
troisième axe de ce contrat local de
santé le territoire soutient les
communes et les professionnels de santé
pour l'implantation de maisons de santé
pluridisciplinaires en 2016 une dotation
de 800000 euros a été votée le but
soutenir les projets de regroupements
médicaux labellisés par l' agence
régionale de santé
les maisons de santé pluridisciplinaires
fleurissent depuis 2010 sur l'hexagone
ces établissements de premier recours
concentre divers professionnels de santé
à saint quentin en yvelines
les projets prennent forme la maison de
santé villa roi ouverte en septembre à
guyancourt rassemble 18 médecins
généralistes spécialistes et auxiliaires
médicaux
le projet de trappes et a été impulsée
par un médecin généraliste et une
sage-femme
depuis le début on a toujours eu
l'objectif de créer une maison de santé
à la fois pour les patientes
ça permet aux patients d'avoir tous les
acteurs de soins de premier recours à
côté de chez eux à proximité sont tous
réunis travail en groupe permet aussi
aux professionnels de santé de
confronter leur avis sur divers cas
médicaux mutualisé l'organisation est
également un véritable avantage pour ces
praticiens à terme trois médecins
généralistes deux sages-femmes quatre
infirmières une psychologue une
orthophoniste et une ostéopathe devrait
travailler dans la structure au départ
médecins remplaçants
le docteur pinsard laventure a adhéré à
l'initiative
il ya plusieurs choses qui m'ont séduit
d'abord c'était le caractère
effectivement de regroupement de
professionnels dans une équipe dynamique
qui était vraiment la priorité donc
c'était vraiment important de pouvoir
dialoguer avec les interlocuteurs sages
femmes infirmières kinés ça c'est la
richesse de la maison de santé
et puis enfin la population de trappes
qui a une population adorable qui sont
vraiment des gens où il ya tout tout
tout est à faire à trappes et il ya des
gens formidables
les patients sont vraiment à l'écouté
puis il ya vraiment une vraie médecine
on va dire à pratiquer avec
l'installation du docteur pinsard
aventure une discipline supplémentaire
sera offerte aux patientes puisque ce
praticien exerce aussi la gynécologie
ses douze professionnels de santé
devraient se regrouper au sein d'une
structure dans le courant du premier
trimestre 2010 8
une structure qui achève ses travaux
juste en face des locaux actuels à
montigny le bretonneux des locaux
devraient être réhabilités cours en 2018
afin d'y accueillir la future msp
d'autres réflexions sont menées à la
verrière plaisir ou encore les
clayes-sous-bois autre lieu autre public
la maison de l'étudiant de l'université
de versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines
possède depuis septembre dernier son
centre de santé un centre présents sur
tous les sites de l'uvs et excuse la
mission principale des services de santé
universitaire au départ c'était la
prévention d'organisation d'avis
médicale obligatoire pour tous les
étudiants cremo inscrit on a une mission
prévention de dépistage d'orientation
d'accueil des étudiants handicapés en
place des aménagements puisqu'on a une
dénégation mdph maison départementale du
handicap
et puis être à l'écouté effectivement de
toute la population étudiante également
sur les problèmes sociaux puisqu'on est
en travail proche avec les assistantes
sociales des psychologues sont également
présents les en premier lieu la visite
médicale obligatoire au préalable un
entretien avec l'infirmière puis un
examen clinique de 40 minutes avec le
médecin
ce sont des consultations qui sont assez
longues elles sont plus longues en
médecine générale on fasse vraiment en
revue avec eux tous les thèmes de santé
des consultations de médecine générale
sont aussi ouvertes tout au long de
l'année
véritable guichet unique le centre de
santé pourraient à plus long terme
développer d'autres consultation en
gynécologie dermatologie médecine du
sport et soins dentaires
le centre espère également étoffer ses
équipes médicales afin d'ouvrir
davantage de plage de rendez vous
à 50 ans navy c'est tout le secteur de
la santé qui se réorganise et pas de
l'institut mutuelle générale de
l'éducation nationale ou encore
l'hôpital de trappes ont fait le tour
un ehpad verra le jour en janvier 2018 à
montigny le bretonneux adossé au château
de la coudre d'établissements pour
personnes âgées dépendantes disposera de
88 places dont 17 lits consacrée à
l'aide sociale
il accueillera notamment des personnes
atteintes du trouble cognitif
les pré réservations sont d'ores et déjà
ouvertes
une résidence seniors devrait ouvrir ses
portes non loin de là durant le premier
semestre 2010 8 à la verrière c'est
l'institut mutuelle générale de
l'éducation nationale qui s'offre une
seconde jeunesse
fondée en 1959 l'établissement est en
reconstruction
le but mettre en synergie les deux
champs de compétence gériatrie et santé
mentale à terme plus de confort et de
rapidité de prise en charge pour les
patients et une plus grande efficacité
pour les équipes médicales
le nouvel institut sera réparti en
quatre poules clinique distincts et
spécifiques
les capacités d'accueil seront augmentés
à c'est que pour l'ehpad fin des travaux
en 2010 neuf autres rafraîchissement
celui de l'hôpital de trappes le groupe
ramsay générale de santé et l'hôpital
privé de l'ouest parisien investissent
deux millions et demi d'euros
l'objectif à grandir et réorganiser les
urgences quatre boxes supplémentaires
sur les six déjà existants deux salles
d'attentes distinctes pour gérer les
flux de patients et améliorer la qualité
et le confort de l'accueil une nouvelle
organisation pour réduire les délais
d'attentes
cinquante mille personnes se rendent aux
urgences de l'hôpital chaque année
l'innovation au service des plus
fragiles c'est le pari de blue line est
à nous nous sommes rendus dans les
locaux de l'entreprise et dans courtoise
être accompagné en toute discrétion et
ne pas révéler sa fragilité ou sa
maladie c'est tout l'objectif de cette
montre connectés créé en 2006 blue line
est à est à la pointe des services et
objets connectés pour les personnes en
perte d'autonomie
prendre soin de vos parents c'est la
mission qu'on s'est donné c'est à dire
de réussir à accompagner des personnes
âgées chez elles ou en ehpad de prendre
soin d'elle détecteur de chute bracelet
géolocaliser bouton d'appel famille et
équipements d'habitat et maisons de
retraite
le quotidien de la start-up soulager
résidents et soignants et en étant
présent à la fois à domicile et en ehpad
on a créé aussi des offres d pad à
domicile quand vous avez dans un
quartier une maison de retraite ont qu
un ehpad vous avec une centaine de
résidents on peut peut-être si
coordonnées délivrer des services à 200
300 personnes âgées qui sont chez elles
compass envie de quitter leur domicile
et qui vont pouvoir bénéficier de
plusieurs types de services est resté
plusieurs années à nouveau chez vers des
objets couplée à une plateforme
d'assistance accessible 24 heures sur 24
mais blue lié à va plus loin en
septembre l'entreprise a lancé blue web
qui permet d'interconnecter syrie la
reconnaissance vocale d'apple avec les
dispositifs domotique pour sécuriser les
gestes du quotidien
en octobre un autre service sarah a été
mise en place via l'iphone et l'apple
watch qui associe assistance et
accompagnement des professionnels de
santé
800 établissements de santé et 25000
français utilisent les solutions de la
start-up élan courtoise
ce qui manque c'est terminé pour
aujourd'hui à très bientôt pour de
nouvelles aventures saint-quentinoise
d'ici là portez vous bien
ciao
[Musique]